after more than a decade in development
disney's newest action adventure epic
called jungle cruise has finally charted
a course into theaters
before you see it here's everything we
know so far
back in 2018 it looked like we'd be
seeing jungle cruise much sooner as the
film pushed through its development
schedule the walt disney company was
prepared to roll the film out as early
as 2019
and set an initial release date for
october of that year that would have
pitted the film against eventual hits
like joker however well before that
release date was upon us disney shifted
the film
there was some speculation at the time
that jungle crews had been moved to
occupy a prime theatrical release window
that had previously been reserved for a
star wars film
remember in 2018 disney was still
purportedly working toward a goal of
releasing a star wars flick every year
alternating between main saga stories
and spin-offs then solo a star wars
story arrived to disappointing box
office returns in may of 2018
setting the stage for a bit of a
re-tooling by 2019 there were no star
wars films planned for 2020 so jungle
cruise was tapped in to compete in the
busy summer box office schedule
we got another potential release date
after that first fall start
july 24th 2020. it was going to be a
classic sweet summer blockbuster just
the way things used to be
unfortunately thanks to the pandemic
that 2020 dates has come and gone
a few rumors circulated that disney
might go the vod route with the first
entry in its franchise but that all
proved to be hearsay
disney remains committed to a
traditional theatrical release for its
adventurous tentpole
fear not disney fans jungle cruise will
enjoy a traditional theatrical release
on july 30th 2021 and it seems like this
one's really going to take
that means this release date comes
almost three full years after the formal
conclusion of filming back in september
2018.
we'll have to wait for the press junkets
to see if johnson and blunt even
remember what the movie's about
mark your calendars after years of
development the first official trailer
finally arrived online in october of
2019
the footage revealed an action-adventure
comedy that owes a lot to previous
period pieces in the sub-genre think of
disney's own pirates of the caribbean
and universal's mummy franchise from the
2000s
we are in serious trouble the trailer
begins by establishing the film as a
period drama set sometime in the early
20th century though not so early that
automobiles aren't prevalent
from there it's more or less non-stop
action and comedy
we get to meet our main characters lily
and frank and we see the two of them
meet and team up
but what we don't see a whole lot of is
the actual jungle crews the characters
are set to embark on
still there's just enough here to hint
that the trip will soon turn
supernatural with help from an ancient
curse
a second full-length trailer that came
down the pike in 2021 is even more
absolutely action-packed
it keeps a focus on blunt and johnson
often in pursuit of or being pursued by
some nasty business
supernatural or otherwise it also
provides a few more glimpses of the
actual cruise in question
there's even some jesse plemon's action
in what looks to be a german u-boat
this is likely the final glimpse of the
project before game time so go ahead and
fire it up
jungle cruise is said to be a rollicking
action comedy vehicle in the vein of
past disney hits like pirates of the
caribbean
as with johnny depp in the first pirates
film one of the keys to the project's
success is picking a star to frame the
film around and then filling out a
compelling ensemble
in the case of jungle cruise the star
roll will be filled by not one but
two stars with experience in both action
and comedy the film's leading man is
dwayne johnson who began circling the
movie as far back as 2015
and finally hopped on board in 2017. in
2018 it was revealed that johnson's
co-star for the film would be emily
blunt who's proven her action chops on
films like edge of tomorrow and a quiet
place
she's also already had major successes
with disney in films like into the woods
and mary poppins returns
both leads are known commodities and by
the looks of the trailers released to
date a lot of the movie's success will
be hanging on their performances while
johnson and blunt are the key leads to
the film they're not the only stars
attached
the film will also feature breaking bad
and fargo standout jesse plemons in a
villainous role
in addition british comedian jack
whitehall stars as the brother of
blunt's character
edgar ramirez plays a mercenary leading
another expedition to the tree of life
and direct competition with the johnson
blunt cruise
billion star paul giamatti is involved
in a role originally described as a
crusty harbormaster
so then it's as star-studded as you
might expect from the franchise disney
hopes will become the successor to
pirates of the caribbean
jungle cruise is a period film that's
heavy on the kind of action comedy blend
that's inspired classics like the
indiana jones films
it's a swashbuckling adventure that will
feature no small number of set pieces
and big effects
the film follows lily a scientist who
makes a shocking discovery in london
that could lead her to the legendary
tree of life
the trouble is the tree lies deep in the
amazon rainforest which means she's got
to travel to south america and set
herself up for transportation
once there she meets frank a jungle
cruise captain who seems more interested
in conning tourists out of their money
than helping anyone to find a place that
sounds like it's make-believe
lily and her brother have plenty of
money to hire frank though so he takes
the job
from there it's an all-out adventure
into the heart of the amazon river but
the journey to the tree of life won't be
easy lily's not the only one trying to
find it of course and it turns out she
and frank may also be contending with an
ancient curse all the elements are there
the quest the elevated fantasy
historical setting
the stylish visual effects heck there's
even an ancient curse
it really is curse of the black pearl on
the amazon river in the best possible
ways
there are certainly worse films to
emulate after all
the film's journey to the big screen
begins with the theme park attractions
opening at disneyland in 1955.
for our purposes though the real road to
a movie version of the ride kicked off
in the 2000s after walt disney pictures
saw major success with pirates of the
caribbean the curse of the black pearl
that film also based on a disney park's
attraction launched an action-adventure
franchise for the studio so disney
started to mind other possible rides for
film material
jungle crew seemed like a natural fit
and in 2006 disney began trying to nail
down a script jungle cruise took what
seemed at the time like a big leap
toward the screen back in 2011
at this time it was reported by ew that
tom hanks and tim allen the duo that
helped to make toy story a hit would
team up again to star in the film
that parry and ultimately fizzled and by
2015 dwayne johnson was expressing
interest in the project
johnson was dubbed the film's official
star in 2017 and by 2018
jungle cruz had begun shooting here we
go
in 2017 with johnson officially on board
to star in the film jungle cruise began
to set up the rest of its creative team
both in front of and behind the camera
johnson as he has in many of his recent
blockbusters took a rather active role
in the process because he's also serving
as one of the project's producers
in the spring of 2017 the film began
searching for a director and johnson
expressed a preference for wonder woman
helmer patty jenkins
jenkins ultimately stayed at warner
brothers to direct a wonder woman sequel
and by the summer of 2017 jeremiah
colette sarah was revealed as the
director after passing on the
opportunity
to direct a suicide squad sequel that
suicide squad film eventually went to
james gunn of guardians of the galaxy
fame so everyone pretty much ended up
where they belonged
though jungle cruise is being positioned
by disney as a crowd-pleasing
action-adventure flick the film began
generating controversy well before its
release
in august of 2018 jack whitehall
announced via instagram that he'd been
cast in the film
it was later revealed that he'd be
playing the brother of emily blunt's
character
that same month the report surfaced from
uk tabloid the sun which revealed
whitehall's character would be among the
first major openly gay characters in a
disney production
describing his character the report said
his character is one who is hugely a
feat
very camp and very funny the report
quickly generated controversy not
because disney would feature an openly
gay character in the film but because of
how the character would reportedly be
portrayed
many social media users worried that
disney was simply leaning back on tired
gay stereotypes for its first major gay
character
others were concerned about who would
play the role that whitehall a straight
man would be playing such a potentially
groundbreaking role for disney instead
of a gay actor was also a point of
contention
disney has not officially responded to
the controversy but whitehall has also
gained defenders since the outrage
we'll just have to wait until july 30th
to see how it all pans out
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one